I just wanted to show the reality of what it's like to have POTS,
especially for me being pregnant with POTS.
Being pregnant makes my POTS worse.
So just to give an idea of what's going on here,
I've been standing in the kitchen,
I've been cooking. I'm not walking on a treadmill,
I'm not doing squats, really.
Quite just easy stuff.
Um, as I'm talking to you,
I'm getting a little out of breath here,
but anyway,
I was standing in the kitchen cooking for the past 15 ish minutes. Here.
You can see my heart rate is about 160
just from standing here talking to you.
Um, the 99 is my oxygen levels.
So this is what happens when you have POTS,
is standing often causes your heart to race.
And even just standing and cooking,
even though I'm not doing anything strenuous,
is causing my heart to race.
A lot of women have shamed me
for not being able to do my dishes while pregnant,
and this is the reason why I can't do my dishes.
The heat makes POTS worse,
so people with POTS generally struggle more in the summertime
in the shower. It's very common for people with POTS
to not be able to shower without a shower stool
because the heat causes the blood to rush to our feet even more.
I would be standing at the sink with hot water running,
overheating, and my heart rate running at about a hundred,
sixty hundred, Sixty five for the duration.
And I don't know about you,
but I can't have my heart rate at 160 for a long amount of time
before my legs start shaking
and I start to feel dizzy and lightheaded.
So that's why I can't do my dishes.